[Musica]
Qual è il colore che meglio rappresenta
la società moderna volta alla
sostenibilità
non ditemelo È una domanda retorica e il
verde Scommetto che molti di voi Stanno
pensando appunto al verde che il colore
che ci connette maggiormente alla natura
l'ecosistema naturale offre una
variegata tavolozza di colori in cui
emerge appunto il verde in tutte le sue
sfumature
il colore verde è anche quello che
sentiamo sfruttare più spesso quando si
parla di azioni sostenibili In effetti
pensate alle politiche Verdi qualcuno le
chiama politiche Green
sicuramente avete letto di queste sui
giornali o ne avete sentito parlare
si potrebbero citare le azioni
intraprese dall'Unione Europea che
riguardano gli stati membri ad esempio
in uno degli ultimi consigli europei si
è stabilito un nuovo obiettivo
l'ottenimento di un'unione Europea a
impatto climatico 0 entro il 2050
Qual è il motore che spinge questi
accordi
è sempre una domanda retorica
in linea generale il contrasto al
cambiamento climatico anche se più
correttamente dovremmo parlare di
contrasto al riscaldamento globale da
diversi decenni le comunità scientifiche
Hanno lanciato l'allarme rispetto al
cambiamento del clima del pianeta
in cui le fonti non rinnovabili sono la
principale causa questa infatti
immettono in atmosfera un enorme
quantità di anidride carbonica che va
poi a sommarsi all'effetto Serra
provocando un inevitabile e
insostenibile talvolta innalzamento
delle temperature
a livello globale ci sono delle cause
siccità inondazioni di Sesto
idrogeologico diffusione di malattie per
fare qualche esempio
pensate che nel 2021 sono state emesse
in atmosfera più di 36 miliardi di
tonnellate di CO2 facendoci fare un
passo indietro rispetto ai progressi che
si stavano facendo e rispetto anche a
quello che si è dimostrato essere il
blocco delle emissioni durante la crisi
pandemica
il settore energia secondo l'istinto che
è l'Istituto per gli studi di politica
internazionale
è responsabile delle emissioni di
anidride carbonica in atmosfera per il
73%,
il settore energia comprende varie voci
fra queste quelle che hanno il peso più
significativo sono il consumo energetico
industriale il settore dei trasporti e
il consumo energetico degli edifici
sul piano locale questa innalzamento
delle temperature provoca un altro
fenomeno di cui non si parla abbastanza
Talvolta è anche sconosciuto il fenomeno
dell'isola di calore
studiare l'isola di calore significa
valutare il comfort degli abitanti e
valutare anche il consumo energetico
degli edifici
quando studiamo il fenomeno dell'isola
di calore dobbiamo analizzare l'ambiente
urbano e capirne le sue caratteristiche
nello specifico in linea generale
possiamo dire l'eccessivo consumo di
suono che si declina in pavimentazione
impermeabili mancanza di vegetazione e
geometria delle città
capiamo per punti di cosa stiamo
parlando
pensate alle nostre strade nere per via
dell'asfalto e sicuramente impermeabili
Queste sono poco riflettenti nei
confronti della radiazione della
radiazione solare
ma al contrario hanno un elevata
capacità termica
sapete che cos'è
È quella caratteristica per cui sia Ci
sono alcuni materiali che hanno la
tendenza ad assorbire grandi quantità di
calore che poi rilasciano nell'ambiente
in momenti successivi
l'infrastruttura urbana banalmente la
forma dei palazzi Ok che riflette e
assorbe il calore durante le ore del
giorno sommata alla caratteristica delle
strade crea una vera e propria trappola
per il calore
generando un altro fenomeno di cui si
parla poco ma che è in costante aumento
in tutta Italia il fenomeno delle notti
tropicali
sono quelle notti in cui la temperatura
non scende mai sotto i 20 gradi
centigradi sono sicura che questa estate
e qualcuno di voi ne ha avuto sentore
pensate che l'anno scorso nel 2021 nella
ricerca sul clima dell'ispra sono state
82 consecutive a Cagliari
Facciamo un passo indietro e torniamo
all'isola di calore ancora
pensate
è dimostrato che un viale alberato a
differenza di uno senza alberature
riesce a fare avere al suolo una
temperatura inferiore fra i quattro e i
10 gradi
la mancanza di vegetazione è una
caratteristica che
le grandi città hanno in comune perché
man mano che l'urbanizzazione aumenta si
sacrifica il verde pubblico che è una
cosa sbagliata perché la vegetazione che
regola il microclima
Esistono varie tecnologie varie
soluzioni innovative per mitigare il
fenomeno dell'isola di calore abbiamo
scelto di concentrarci sui Giardini
verticali
i giardini verticali sono in grado di
ridurre gli impatti negativi
dell'organizzazione e di creare modelli
che sono soprattutto replicabili e
sostenibili dal punto di vista
ambientale
il muro vegetale o più correttamente
murvegetal ideato dal botanico
ricercatore francese Patrick Blanc
aposto le basi per un cambiamento nella
progettazione architettonica che vede
uno stretto connubio con la natura le
specie vegetali reperibili appunto in
natura
rispondono a determinate esigenze
progettuali che possiamo elencare in
esigenze estetiche funzionali e
bioclimatiche
pensate
a una facciata di un edificio quando è
esposta durante i mesi caldi al sole può
raggiungere una temperatura fino ai 50
gradi
al contrario in inverno quella stessa
facciata può essere investita da denti
freddi oppure dalle precipitazioni
attraverso il giardino verticale è
possibile smorzare queste alte basse
temperature producendo tutta una serie
di benefici in più sicuramente la
regolazione termica interna gli edifici
infatti grazie alla presenza della
struttura è possibile mantenere una
temperatura quasi costante all'interno
degli ambienti
migliorare la qualità dell'aria le
specie vegetali messe a dimora su parete
sono in grado di assorbire e
metabolizzare le polveri sottili Pensate
ai particolari come i pm10
benefici psicofisici esistono ricerche
in psicologia che dimostrano che la
semplice percezione del Verde provoca
beneficio nell'osservatore
ancora riduzione dell'inquinamento
sonoro acustico
pensate a quei quartieri Magari poco
vegetati in cui c'è la presenza di molto
traffico il rumore delle auto Il rumore
dei mezzi pubblici si ripercuoti
inevitabilmente sulla vita di cittadini
e cittadini attraverso il giardino
verticale è possibile assorbire quel
rumore ridurre Il riverbero
sono da ammirare alcuni nuclei urbani
che hanno messo in atto una vera e
propria trasformazione in cui la
vegetazione occupa una posizione
centrale e fondamentale e fra questi
sicuramente Berlino fin dal 1980 ha
attuato una serie di strategie atti a
contenere l'impatto negativo rispetto al
consumo di suolo l'abbattimento degli
inquinanti e altri aspetti
in Italia abbiamo molti esempi di
giardini verticali vi Cito uno che ci è
piaciuto particolarmente un giardino
verticale messo a dimora sulla parete di
un centro commerciale a Rozzano in
provincia di Milano e grande circa 1.250
metri quadri ed è quello stesso giardino
che contribuisce al bilanciamento
termico dell'edificio
anche la ricerca si muove verso la
mappatura delle isole di calore quindi
iniziamo ad individuarle attraverso il
satellite lo sta facendo Sassari lo
hanno fatto l'università di Trento e
Bologna alcune anche promuovendo nelle
loro ricerche alcune soluzioni tutte
comunque che vedono la vegetazione come
componente fondamentale
vorrei mostrarvi alcune immagini
che vogliono solo dare una suggestione
vogliono solo aiutarvi a immaginare come
possono cambiare le città se adottassero
in modo diffuso i giardini verticali
con il mio amico e collega Luca tempo fa
abbiamo deciso di unire le nostre
competenze e di pensare un prototipo di
verde verticale che fosse completamente
naturale
dopo più di un anno di studi abbiamo
ideato un prototipo lo abbiamo costruito
realizzato facile da assemblare e
mettere in opera e ne abbiamo brevettato
il modello disegno Questo è il prototipo
ha fatto un po' strecciata e su parete
da circa due anni e ne studiamo
costantemente il comportamento sia per
quanto riguarda la tenuta della
struttura portante sia per quanto
riguarda la messa Dimora delle specie
vegetali Io sono un architetto del
paesaggio lui è un ingegnere nessuno è
un agronomo quindi dobbiamo capirci
qualcosa
misura circa 80 cm di altezza per un
metro e mezzo di larghezza ed è posto a
una piccola distanza da quella che
chiamiamo parete ospitante la camera
d'aria che viene così a generarsi
unitamente alla geometria del nostro
prototipo è in grado di mantenersi
costantemente asciutta e ventilata
Quando avverrà posto su parete insieme
agli altri moduli e andrà a disegnare il
giardino verticale complessivo
comprenderà anche un circuito di farti
irrigazione chiuso con una cisterna
posta a quote basse questa cisterna
verrà sopra dimensionata rispetto alla
superficie della parete perché perché
grazie ai giardini verticali È possibile
recuperare l'acqua che cade su parete
quindi noi la convogliamo e la
sfruttiamo la riutilizziamo
abbiamo deciso di chiamarlo verdales
alcuni di voi hanno già sorriso Sono due
le ragioni che ci hanno spinto in questa
direzione La prima è porre l'accento
sulla parola verde sul colore verde che
deve diventare parola simbolo del futuro
delle città
La seconda è richiamare l'attenzione su
una tradizione che in Sardegna prende
avvio A partire dagli anni 70 del
Novecento la tradizione dei murales
numerosi Infatti sono i centri
dell'Isola Che si arricchiscono grazie
ad opere diffuse di artisti locali e
internazionali
e alcune periferie di alcune città
vengono rigenerate artisticamente con
verbale se abbiamo l'obiettivo di
inserirci in questa tradizione con una
piccolissima differenza le pennellate
sono sostituite dalla cromatura del
fogliame e delle fioriture
per concludere le principali
caratteristiche di verbales è più in
generale dei Giardini verticali sono la
regolazione termica la depurazione
dell'aria
l'abbattimento acustico e degli
inquinanti l'ostacolo Alla diffusione
del fuoco la valorizzazione degli
edifici è ultimo ma non ultimo perché
dell'importanza che ha l'incremento
della biodiversità un aspetto che si
sottovaluta fin troppo all'interno dei
centri urbani
le città sono chiamate ad agire ora a
migliorare la qualità della vita di
cittadini e cittadini a creare
attrattività grazie ai giardini
verticali a creare al lavoro a mitigare
il fenomeno dell'isola di calore
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]